did you watch tucker yesterday with uh
tony bublinski the guest he had on no
i've seen take the outtakes from it
robin i didn't watch the whole show
what what's your reaction with the story
of tony coming out with the partnership
of honor i know you went into it briefly
earlier when i was asking you about
bezos and cnn
but what are your thoughts about it and
why is it that no one's covering it it's
like almost saying
i heard somebody say the other day i
think it was on 60 minutes or one of the
hosts said well we won't cover because
everything is speculation nothing we
don't
cover stories like this if it's if it
isn't 100
what are your thoughts about what we're
seeing with tony and hunter biden well
first that comments a lie
they spent three and a half years
covering a russian story about trump
that turned out to be totally
false uh both the new york times the
washington post got pulitzer prizes
for covering lies which uh they never to
return the prizes but
their entire prize was based on lies so
if you're on the left
you can do anything you want to and
they'll protect you if you're on the
right they can smear you
and claim that it's good journalism uh
let's just start with with honesty
second i just did a 30 minute video
which is available at gingrich 360
uh on bro the biden family corruption
and i think i outline it with quotes and
with video
and lay the whole thing out it's much
more than hunter it's it's a it's a
family business
it's his two uncles it's his father uh
and they were just out going around the
planet scooping up money
uh clearly a blatant uh violation
of public trust uh and and uh and it's
an astonishing story well it involves
hundreds of millions of dollars now this
is not some small
you know jaywalking problem um i
i have seen excerpts from polinsky
you know he was a naval officer he has a
good reputation
we have some mutual friends who think
very highly of him
but again you have what you have is the
entire
establishment twitter
facebook um all the major media
are like they're like they're like a
greek phalanx
they're all lined up to protect biden
and so they want to make sure that the
bunny in the basement is safe
while they go and attack the bear and
that's what this race is all about you
think the world's dangerous
and we need a bear in which case donald
trump's a pretty good candidate
or do you think that donald trump is the
problem and we could really survive as a
country
with a bunny rabbit as our president as
our president which i think is
just laughable impossible and and i'm
very interested to see how people vote
next week
because i think the more we watch biden
you know things like referring to
kamala harris's wife which he did
yesterday
or the day before referring twice to
george when he met donald trump
or announcing he was running for the
senate three or four days ago
i mean the more you watch biden the more
you know
this is not a guy who is really ready
for prime time
[Music]
you